Teotihuacan-- along
the Avenue of the Dead,
multiple structures
show evidence
of a catastrophic
fire that consumed
portions of the temple complex.
The damage has been attributed
to an uprising at the end
of the sixth century, just
before the population entirely
vanished without a trace.
This structure in
particular, in spite of
the many modern restorations--
NARRATOR: According to
archaeologist Leopoldo Batras,
who surveyed this site
in the late 19th century,
the damage seemed too
extensive to be attributed
to simple torch flames
leading researchers to explore
alternative explanations
NARRATOR: Could the curious
finds of mica and mercury
at the site help corroborate the
theory that the burn marks we
see along the Avenue of
the Dead are from some sort
of mechanical explosion?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and they suggest that like
the Great Pyramid at Giza
and other sites
throughout the globe,
the structures at
Teotihuacan may
have once served as an
electromagnetic power plant.
Researchers proposed
that the pyramids
constructed around the world
are, in fact, power plants.
This is based on
our new knowledge
that they in fact
are designed to tap
the resonant power of the
Earth, and then to distribute it
around the world.
Teotihuacan matches
precisely this model.
It's built over caverns.
It had liquid mercury and mica
incorporated into its design.
And we know that the Gods
came and left from this place.
So when we put all
the pieces together,
we're looking at Teotihuacan
as yet another example of
the power plants of the gods.
If it was a technological
system that was generating
a lot of energy at
some point, there could
have been a malfunction in it.
But there was energy.
The mica found at the site
was supposed to shield it.
And mercury was also
found at the site
seems to have been used.
Perhaps we had some
kind of accident
there at some point in time.
NARRATOR: If Teotihuacan
served as an ancient power
plant, generating
electromagnetic energy, just
what role did the
liquid mercury,
recently discovered at the
site, play in such a scenario?
There's stories of mercury
being used in spacecrafts.
And some of the
ancient Indian epics
talk about mercury as
part of the vimanas
and the mechanics
of these craft.
So here we have the idea
that this mercury, that's
being found at
archaeological sites,
is really part of the
propulsion of some of the craft
that the extraterrestrials
we're using here on Earth.